Wes Bos: To
understand classes, let's take
this dog function here, which
refused to create Snickers and
Sunny, and turn that into an ES6
class. There's two ways to make
a class in ES6. There's a class
declaration and a class
expression. A class
declaration simply goes, you
write the keyword class, and
then you type the name of the
class, dog, and then you open up
the class block. A class
expression looks like this,
const dog = class, and you open
and close your class block. Very
similar to how you can stick a
function inside of a variable,
or you can just go ahead and
declare the actual function
itself. I much prefer to this
first right here. Their use case
is for this, but we'll go ahead
and use class dog here.
Inside of the body of your class,
there are a bunch of methods.
The only method that is
absolutely required when you're
building a class is what's
called a constructor. That is
what happens when someone
creates a new version. We'll say
constructor. Now, you notice
that I didn't say constructor
function. It's constructor open
close parenthesis, open close
your actual block. All of
your methods that live inside of
a class are going to look
exactly like that. It's exactly
the same as our object shorthand
from methods, that we were
showing earlier in our object
improvement video. Now, that
constructor video gets called
when someone makes a new one.
What is it going to take? It's
going to take a name, because we
pass it the name, and it's going
to take a breed, because we pass
it the breed. We can just
take these two parameters, pop
them in there, and the same goes
for the code that happens when
something is created. We'll say
this.name = whatever they pass
the name, and this.breed is
whatever they passed in as the
breed. Now we're done that part
here. We need to now work on
these prototype methods, bark
and cuddle. We can go into here,
and you might think you do this,
comma bark, open close. That is
almost right, but you do not
need this comma, or you cannot
have this comma here. Whenever
you have a method inside of a
class, do not put a comma. It
might seem weird to you, but
that's just the syntax. If you
have one there, it's going to
break. We'll give ourselves
that method there. Then inside
of the bark, you can just move
this. Console.log, bark, bark,
my name is this.name. Same goes
for the cuddle method. Of course,
if your method had any
parameters, you could put them
in here, but we don't in this
case. I'm going to move it up
into there. That should
create a dog, which we are
allowed to call new against, and
we should pass it Snickers and
King Charles. If I say that and
refresh, I should be able to
call all the methods I
previously was. We'll say
Snickers is a dog, Sunny is a
dog. snickers.bark
and sunny.bark.
Good. That is a very basics
of a class. However there are
quite a few more things that we
can learn about it. There's one
thing called a static method. In
order to understand what a
static method is, think back to
when we were working with array.
from and array.of. You know
that we have array.from which
will create an array out of
something like a NodeList or
arguments. You know that we have
array.of, which only lives on
top of array. If I create,
and say array.of one, two, three,
four, that will create as an
array, but that of is not a
method on every single array. If
I create myself a new array
names = Wes and Kate, I don't
have names.of. That's not a
method. That's because it only
lives on array directly. It's
not inherited by all of them.
If we also wanted something
similar to that for our dog,
maybe like info, we could say
static info. What that would do
is console.log some information...
a dog is better than a
cat by 10 times. It's probably
low, but we can work with it.
Now, if I say Sunny and I say
sunny.info, it doesn't work.
Why not? Because Sunny is an
instance of dog. How do I get
this info? Because it is a
static method, we can only call
it on dog directly. Then we get
the information. That's a static
method that lives inside of it.
We can also use getters and
setters on classes, just as you
would an object. You simply say
get, let's use the description.
When someone asks for snickers.
description, we will return this.
name is a this.breed type of
dog. Then we should be able to
say snickers.description, and it
will tell us. We used a
getter there. It's not a method,
it's a property that is computed
when you pull on it. Similarly,
if you wanted to also work with
a setter, say set nicknames, and
we'll just say whatever the
person actually passes in, which
is going to be the value. We
can say this.nick. We can't use
nicknames again, because we're
actually using that as a setter
here, so we have to have another
variable called nick. We say =
value, and then I'll just trim
against it. Sometimes people
pass in stuff with some spaces.
That's just an example of when
you might want to use a setter.
Give that a save. Say
snickers.nicknames = snicky, and
a whole bunch of spaces. There
we go. Now we can also have a
getter. Let's say snickers.
nicknames won't give us anything.
Why not? We haven't set a getter
for it. Get nicknames = return
this.nick. We'll Snickers.
nicknames and then snickers.
nickname get, it returns us just
that. Why? Because we put a
setter where we trimmed it as it
came in, and then a getter where
we removed it. We could also
say like toUppercase. Then you
set it as snicky with a whole
bunch of spaces. You get it as
uppercase Snicky. That's a
setter and getter where you have
the same property value.
That is the basics of a class.
Let's look at some more advanced
examples of what you can do with
it.